Dr. Zakia, I would call upon you to
resolve one of the most common disputes
in the Muslim Ummah during the month of
Ramadan regarding the number of raqat
that are prayed in the tarawi or the
kyel or the night prayer. Is it eight or
should it be 20? Our beloved prophet
wasallam said it's mentioned in say
bkari volume number one in the book of
salah had number 472 he said that when a
person asks that how should he offer
theamal the prophet said that he should
offer in two raat followed by two raat
followed by two raat followed by two
raat and so on and when he fears that
dawn is approaching he should offer one
raat so all the rakat become wither
become odd that means is you can pray as
many as you wish later on have one
number an odd number so that everything
becomes odd. So as far as the number of
rakas are concerned, you can pray as
many as you wish. But as far as the
practice of Mhamad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam is concerned, this mentioned in
say Bkari volume number two in the book
of Tahud had number 1147
that Aisha may Allah be pleased with
her. She says that the prophet
while offering in Ramadan used to always
offer 11 raat not more than 11 raat and
this he used to do even other months
that means eight raat of and three of so
it becomes 8 + 3 11 and there are
various other hadith which always say
that all the hadith that we find of the
prophet wasallam whether it being Sai
Bkari Sai Muslim all of them said that
he prayed lakat or this 11 lakh.